Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。
Right, let's get on with today's episode. In today's episode, I am joined by a qualified independent financial advisor. It's never too early to start looking at your finances and financial planning. It doesn't need to be as scary as you think it might be. Stay tuned right to the end to get all of Ian's top tips and I hope you find it useful. you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with with Dr. Marianne Trent. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. When it comes to talking about money and finances, it can sometimes feel a bit like a dirty word or something that we shouldn't do. And especially when we look at how we've been raised, we can experience something
好了，让我们开始今天的话题。今天，我邀请到了一位合格的独立财务顾问。开始关注财务和财务规划永远不会太早。这并不像你想象的那么可怕。请务必听到最后，获取Ian的所有专业建议，希望这对你有帮助。如果你正打算成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南吧。通过这个播客，你将走上获得从业资格的道路。这是由Marianne Trent博士主持的《Aspiring Psychologist Podcast》。你好，欢迎收听《Aspiring Psychologist Podcast》。我是Marianne Trent博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。谈到金钱和财务时，有时会觉得这像是一个禁忌词，或者是不该谈论的话题。特别是当我们回顾自己的成长经历时，我们可能会经历一种
called money trauma. And this is the case that we often find when we're working with clients as well, who might have been raised in chaotic situations where there wasn't enough money or where it was their job to budget and make sure there was enough money to go around. Of course, in psychology and mental health, often the relevant experience roles might well be lower paid than might be ideal. And so it can feel like there's not enough money to go around and there's not enough money to even consider our financial planning and our options. Today, I'm joined by a qualified independent financial advisor and we're going to talk all things money specifically for this audience of aspiring psychologists and mental health. If you're watching on YouTube and you find it useful,
所谓的“金钱创伤”。在与客户合作时，我们也经常发现这种情况，他们可能在经济拮据的混乱环境中长大，或者从小就负责预算，确保家里有足够的钱维持生活。当然，在心理学和心理健康领域，相关的实习岗位薪水往往低于理想水平。因此，人们可能会觉得钱不够花，甚至没有余力去考虑财务规划和选择。今天，我邀请到了一位合格的独立财务顾问，我们将专门为立志成为心理学家和心理健康从业者的听众探讨金钱问题。如果你正在YouTube上观看并觉得有用，
I'd love it if you'd drop us your feedback or questions in the comments. Please do also like and subscribe to the channel. And if you're listening on podcast and it's on Spotify or Apple podcast, please do rate and review because it helps us to bring this podcast to more people that might find it useful. It was an absolute pleasure speaking with Ian and I hope you find it a useful listen as well. I will catch up with you on the other side. Hi, I just want to welcome along our guest for today, Ian Dempsey. Ian is an independent financial advisor, the money man. Welcome, Ian. Hello. Thank you so much for being here. People who listen regularly to the podcast will not be surprised that I first stumbled over you on LinkedIn. That is your main hangout, isn't it? Yeah, it is. It's just something that's grown exponentially over the last few years and just been a really powerful tool for me to kind of grow a business, leave employment, get out on my own do it my way and it's
欢迎在评论区留下你的反馈或问题。也请点赞并订阅频道。如果你是在Spotify或Apple Podcast上收听播客，请务必评分和评论，因为这能帮助我们将播客带给更多可能需要的人。与Ian的交谈非常愉快，希望你也能从中受益。稍后见。嗨，我想欢迎今天的嘉宾Ian Dempsey。Ian是一位独立财务顾问，也就是“金钱先生”。欢迎你，Ian。你好。非常感谢你能来。经常收听播客的朋友们一定不会惊讶，我是先在LinkedIn上发现你的。那是你的主要阵地，对吧？是的，确实是。过去几年里，它呈指数级增长，对我来说，它已成为拓展业务、辞去工作、独立创业并按自己的方式行事的强大工具，而且
it's been great I love it I love it ditto in a couple of days time it will be two years since I became fully self-employed so um absolutely think that LinkedIn has been a really big part of that for me it's a great platform do you know spookily it's about the same kind of time frame for me as well so I think we must have kind of made that jump around about the same time so i've had i've just hit the one year anniversary for where i am now and previously to that it was a year so near enough to the day we're almost kind of took the jump at the same time amazing well it's been lovely having you as a diving buddy i hope the water's been warm for you it's been choppier times but we're getting there
这感觉太棒了，我非常喜欢。我也是，再过几天我就全职自雇满两年了。所以我绝对认为LinkedIn对我来说起到了非常重要的作用，它是一个很棒的平台。你知道吗，巧合的是，我们的时间跨度也差不多。我想我们大概是在同一时间迈出了那一步。我现在刚满一周年，之前也工作了一年，所以几乎是在同一天，我们几乎同时跳了出来。太棒了，很高兴能有你作为“潜水伙伴”，希望水温对你来说还算温暖。虽然经历过波折，但我们正在好转。
okay so you know i wanted to have you on because it feels like actually something i've not spoken about on the podcast at all is money it can be a really tricky area to navigate especially when you don't have so much of it um you know, like many of my audience are likely to be working kind of band four NHS, possibly band five, possibly band six. And I had a quick look at what that is. So band four is yearly 25 grand starting salary with a monthly take home of 1600. Band five is a gross 28,000 a year with a take home monthly of 1700. And band six, if people are working at band six, it's 35,000 a year starting with take home of 2000. But of course, that's some of that will be student loan. But I think the student loan only kicks in at a
好的，我想邀请你来是因为我觉得我在播客中从未谈论过金钱，这可能是一个很难驾驭的领域，尤其是当你手头并不宽裕的时候。你知道，我的许多听众可能在NHS工作，处于4级、5级或6级岗位。我快速查了一下这些职位的薪资。4级起薪是年薪2.5万英镑，每月到手1600英镑。5级年薪总额2.8万英镑，每月到手1700英镑。6级起薪是年薪3.5万英镑，每月到手2000英镑。当然，其中一部分会用于偿还学生贷款。但我认为学生贷款只有在达到
certain amount. So band fours won't pay loan um unless they do it as an additional payment but sometimes it's useful to think about what amount we're talking about and some of these people will be footloose and fancy free some of them might already have children and so in these difficult times that we navigate it's tricky to think about what what we do with our money and how how we do it isn't it it's a massive challenge it's a massive challenge for everybody and if you just kind of look at the squeeze that we've all gone through in the last two years where you've been through a pandemic you've been through like markets crashing a real squeeze on people's finances you've had furlough people losing jobs then we've kind of come out of that and to talk of a recession
一定金额后才会开始扣除。所以4级员工通常不会扣除贷款，除非他们选择额外还款。但有时思考一下我们谈论的金额很有用。这些人中，有些人可能无拘无束，有些人可能已经有了孩子。因此，在当前我们所处的困难时期，思考如何处理金钱以及如何操作确实很棘手，不是吗？这是一个巨大的挑战，对每个人来说都是巨大的挑战。如果你看看过去两年我们所经历的紧缩，经历了疫情、市场崩盘、个人财务的真正紧缩，经历了休假、失业，然后我们走出了困境，又谈论起经济衰退，
inflation going rampant it's a real choppy time for people to kind of manage their finances whether you're managing a household just on your own when you're living with your folks whether you're trying to raise a family and kind of it costs a lot of money to do this stuff and life is getting more and more expensive um and as you know that a lot of industries the wages are going up at a at the same kind of level of pay so effectively if your wages aren't going up at that same pace as the rate of inflation you're almost well in real terms you're losing money year-on-year which is a real challenge for a lot of people but there's lots of things that you can do to kind of make the most of your money and that's that's kind of part of what we're going to talk about today and hopefully give you some
通货膨胀猖獗，这对人们管理财务来说是一个非常动荡的时期。无论你是独自管理家庭，还是与父母同住，亦或是试图抚养家庭，这些事情都需要花费很多钱，生活变得越来越昂贵。而且如你所知，许多行业的工资增长并没有跟上通货膨胀的速度。所以实际上，如果你的工资增长速度赶不上通胀率，那么从实际价值来看，你每年都在亏钱，这对很多人来说是一个真正的挑战。但有很多事情你可以做来充分利用你的金钱，这正是我们今天要讨论的一部分，希望能给你一些
ideas some tips some ways to kind of make that money stretch out a little bit further and just give you a little bit of an insight as to what a financial advisor does really great because i know sometimes the temptation when we don't understand something or if it feels confusing is to run away and hide and bury our heads um i'm guessing you're gonna say that's probably not the wisest course of action ian not not at all i'm like money's a really emotive subject right and if we talk about money there are a lot of emotions that kind of sit behind that and and kind of do what you do marianne you'll know the kind of the thinking the thought process the mind how all that works behind
想法、建议和一些让钱更耐用的方法，并让你对财务顾问的工作有一个小小的了解。太棒了，因为我知道有时当我们不理解某事或感到困惑时，诱惑就是逃避、隐藏并把头埋起来。我猜你会说这可能不是最明智的做法，Ian。一点也不。金钱是一个非常情绪化的主题，对吧？如果我们谈论金钱，背后会有很多情绪。正如你所做的，Marianne，你会了解背后的思维过程、心态以及它是如何运作的，
it but a lot of that is and how you manage your money is influenced by your parents so how your parents manage money how you were brought up to manage money was it scarce was it in abundance and that has a big impact on how you look after your finances moving forward. But one of the worst things you can do is the old ostrich of sticking your head in the sand whenever there's a challenge, whenever there's an issue or a problem. And that's really difficult to do because sometimes that stuff's really stressful. And I've been there, I've done it. This isn't me kind of saying preach preach preach it's like these are things that I've done in the past and I've been in debt and buried my head in the sand because there's a lot of shame attached to stuff like that and you think I shouldn't have a credit
但很大程度上，你如何管理金钱受到父母的影响。父母如何管理金钱、你从小被教导如何管理金钱——是匮乏还是富足——这对你未来如何打理财务有很大影响。但你能做的最糟糕的事情之一就是像鸵鸟一样，每当遇到挑战、问题或麻烦时就把头埋进沙子里。这真的很难做到，因为有时这些事情压力很大。我也经历过，我也做过。这不是我在说教，而是我过去做过的事情。我曾经负债累累，把头埋在沙子里，因为这种事情会带来很多羞耻感。你会想，我不应该有信用卡，
card or I shouldn't have this or I shouldn't have a loan I shouldn't be behind on payments but sometimes you are and that's the reality of it and i think to improve your finances or to get a better handle on it one of the things that you have to be able to do is be completely honest with yourself it's been able to look in the mirror and just be honest with yourself if you've got a partner involved be really honest with your partner and that can feel really challenging it did for me like i hid my debts for the best part of three years from my partner had the conversation just said look this is where we're at she was like well why didn't you tell me sooner that was it why didn't you tell me sooner let's figure out how we get out of it
我不应该有这个，我不应该有贷款，我不应该拖欠付款，但有时你确实会遇到这种情况，这就是现实。我认为要改善财务状况或更好地掌控它，你必须做的一件事就是对自己完全诚实。能够照照镜子，对自己诚实。如果有伴侣，也要对伴侣完全诚实，这可能会让人感到非常困难。对我来说就是这样，我向伴侣隐瞒了近三年的债务。后来进行了谈话，我说：“看，这就是我们的现状。”她问：“那你为什么不早点告诉我？”就是这样，为什么不早点告诉我？让我们想办法解决它。
and that was it and I'd spent three years of stress and worry by not being in control of my finances granted a few years back but it was it tough. And I think, like, go back to what you said, burying your head in the sand and just ignoring this stuff, it doesn't go away. It's just compounding a problem of whether you're kind of got really expensive kind of outgoings, whether you kind of really need to earn more money, whatever it is, but running away from your problems very rarely solves them.
就是这样。我因为没有掌控好财务而经历了三年的压力和担忧，虽然那是几年前的事了，但确实很艰难。我认为，回到你刚才说的，把头埋在沙子里忽视这些问题，它们并不会消失。这只会让问题加剧，无论是因为你有非常昂贵的开支，还是因为你需要赚更多的钱，无论是什么原因，逃避问题很少能解决问题。
Yeah, and there's just so many parallels here with mental health isn't there you know that that we can think that it's going to get better um if we just kind of ignore it and it doesn't but of course mental health can be so impacted upon by finances can't it um you know the two are very much interwoven and the idea of financial trauma as well either from you know growing up not having enough money or from just the ideas like you said that our parents passed down to us you know money doesn't grow on trees you know you're being frivolous you don't need to spend that you know my mum is definitely um I think of her approach to money is um you know pounds look look after the pennies and the pounds look after themselves.
是的，这与心理健康有很多相似之处，不是吗？我们可能会认为如果我们忽视它，它就会好转，但事实并非如此。当然，心理健康会受到财务的极大影响，不是吗？两者是紧密交织在一起的。还有“财务创伤”的概念，无论是源于成长过程中没有足够的钱，还是源于你所说的父母传给我们的观念——你知道，“钱不是长在树上的”，“你太挥霍了”，“你不需要花那个钱”。我妈妈绝对是……我想她对待金钱的态度是，“省下便士，英镑自然会照顾好自己”。
And if she was taking me out for lunch and going to a shop, I could have any sandwich I wanted. But if I didn't pick egg, which was the cheapest, I'd be in trouble. She'd be annoyed. Like, that's how I grew up with money. Yeah. I mean, it's quite similar. I kind of grew up on both sides of the fence so my dad ran his own business as an ifa and i've ended up doing it i don't know why um
如果她带我出去吃午饭并去商店，我可以买任何我想要的汉堡。但如果我不选鸡蛋口味的（那是当时最便宜的），我就会有麻烦。她会很生气。这就是我从小接触金钱的方式。是的。我的情况也差不多。我是在两种截然不同的环境下长大的，我父亲经营着自己的独立财务顾问公司，而我最终也做了这一行，我不知道为什么……
my mum on the other side kind of didn't have a lot of money so i've kind of seen both sides of it um and it's like it's a blend of the two in the middle for me like there's times when i could over the years i've certainly done i've just been completely reckless and thought stuff it'll come back at some point but it it's it's hard managing that stuff and i think if you look generationally at where your parents or where your grandparents were there's a few factors that you need to think about when you look at that is actually they probably got a lot more bang for their buck in terms of their take home pay like how much could you buy a house for i've i've had clients that have bought three or four bedroom houses over the years like 18 000 pound and where would you get that now you just don't get it it's impossible um they get a lot
我母亲那边没有多少钱，所以我看到了两面。对我来说，这是一种中间的融合。多年来，确实有几次我完全鲁莽，心想“管它呢，总会回来的”。但管理这些事情很难。如果你从代际角度看你的父母或祖父母所处的时代，当你审视这些时，你需要考虑几个因素：实际上，他们的工资购买力可能要高得多。比如买房，多年来我有客户以1.8万英镑的价格买下了三四居室的房子，现在去哪找这种价格？根本不可能。他们得到的
more bang for their buck their take-home pay the whole structure of work was very different and you've only got to just take a little bit of reflection time and look at yourself and think about how many adverts have you been emailed this morning how many have you seen on tv how many have you seen on social media on the radio or wherever it's thousands and thousands every day that are all designed to suck that money out of your pocket and pay somebody and it's very hard to kind of push back against that because the whole construct of society, marketing and social media is to suck that money out of your pocket and get you spending money. And it's so easy to do because you can get into debt now. Like you can get credit for a pair of jeans that cost 50 quid.
购买力更强，工作结构也完全不同。你只需要花一点时间反思一下自己，想想今天早上你收到了多少广告邮件？你在电视、社交媒体、广播或其他地方看到了多少广告？每天有成千上万个广告，它们的设计目的就是把钱从你的口袋里掏出来，付给别人。要抵制这种诱惑非常困难，因为整个社会结构、营销和社交媒体的目的就是把钱从你的口袋里掏出来，让你消费。这太容易做到了，因为你现在可以轻易负债。比如，你可以为一条50英镑的牛仔裤申请信贷。
You can pay it over three months. And that stuff just didn't exist 20, 30 years ago. You just couldn't do it you had to have a great relationship with your bank manager and maybe go to church with them on a sunday and take them in and out of the pipe to be able to do it and that's the stuff that you used to be able to do now it's anybody and everybody can get credit and it's a it's a billion pound industry in the uk and that's i think that's massively part of the problem because it's just so freely available. And we don't have to leave the house to spend now, do we?
你可以分三个月支付。这种事情在20、30年前根本不存在。你根本做不到，你必须与银行经理保持良好的关系，也许周日和他们一起去教堂，才能办到。那是过去的做法，现在任何人都可以获得信贷，这在英国是一个价值数十亿英镑的产业。我认为这是问题的重要组成部分，因为它太容易获得了。而且我们现在不需要出门就能消费，对吧？
Whereas, you know, before the internet, you absolutely would have had to go out. And I think it's easier to spend money when you're not having to actually handle the paper money as well, isn't it? Oh, it's huge. And that was a big problem for me. And the one thing that I did to kind of break that cycle was it was the old, like back in the, back in old school days before bank accounts and credit cards, it was a brown envelope method and it was effectively, you'd get your pay and you'd get a lump of cash on your brown envelope. And then you'd probably go home, sit down with your partner and say, right,
而在互联网出现之前，你绝对必须出门。而且我认为当你不需要真正处理纸币时，花钱更容易，不是吗？哦，这影响巨大。这对我来说是个大问题。我打破这种循环所做的一件事，就是回到老派的做法——在银行账户和信用卡出现之前，那是“棕色信封法”。实际上，你拿到工资，在棕色信封里装上一笔现金。然后你可能会回家，和伴侣坐下来商量：“好吧，
this is what we've got to pay out this month. What goes where? And that would go for your bills. That would go for your shopping. That would go for your bills that would go for your shopping that would go for clothes that would go for wherever you'd have a series of brown envelopes to do that and even working in financial services in in banking up until about six years ago i still struggled to get a hold of my finances because it was of what i'd done previously in life and and spent a lot of money on nonsense and just ran up debts. The way that I broke that was exactly that, by having cash and physically taking cash out
这个月我们要支付这些。钱该怎么分配？”这笔钱用于账单，这笔钱用于购物，这笔钱用于衣服，无论去哪，你都会有一系列棕色信封来处理。即使在金融服务行业工作，直到大约六年前，我仍然难以掌控自己的财务，因为我过去的生活方式，在无意义的事情上花了很多钱，背负了债务。我打破这种方式的方法正是如此，通过使用现金并亲自取出钱。
because you're then acutely aware of how much money you're spending on crap, if I want a better phrase, because it's tap, tap, tap with the card. 10, 15, 20 quid a day can just disappear at a rate of knots. And if you're talking about a salary of two grand a month, you only need to do that four or five times throughout the month and you've easily spent a few hundred pounds that you probably didn't have. It's so easy to do, so easy to do. Such interesting food for thought.
因为这样你就会敏锐地意识到你在“垃圾”上花了多少钱（如果我能用更好的词的话），因为刷卡太容易了。每天10、15、20英镑可能会迅速消失。如果你的月薪是2000英镑，你一个月只需要这样刷四五次，你就很容易花掉几百英镑，而这些钱你可能根本没有。这太容易做到了，太容易了。真是发人深省。
And I think I'm aware there's a bank, a free bank account that allows you to do those pots within it, isn't it? I think does Starling do that, which can be really useful? You're my face lit up when you said that. I talk to every client about that account. I'm pretty good with money now, right? So as you'd expect, kind of doing what I do. But we moved all of our bank accounts to Starling about three years ago.
我知道有一个免费的银行账户允许你在里面设置“小金库”，对吧？我想Starling银行有这个功能，非常有用？当你提到这个时，我的脸都亮了。我跟每个客户都谈论那个账户。我现在很擅长理财，对吧？正如你所料，做我这一行。但我们大约三年前把所有的银行账户都转到了Starling。
So we've got individual accounts each. We've got a joint account and I've got my business account. And it absolutely changed the way I manage money. And I tell clients exactly the same because part of what I do with the client is to go through a budget planner. And I've kind of rejigged that slightly. So rather than call it a budget planner, I call it a survive and thrive list. So split a sheet of A4 paper down the middle.
我们每个人都有个人账户，我们有一个联名账户，我还有一个企业账户。它彻底改变了我管理金钱的方式。我告诉客户完全一样的话，因为我与客户工作的一部分就是进行预算规划。我稍微调整了一下。与其称之为预算规划，我称之为“生存与繁荣清单”。在一张A4纸中间画一条线。
On the left-hand side, write down what you need to survive. So that's your fixed costs, your bills, your mortgage, your car insurance, house insurance, food, that kind of stuff. And on the right-hand side, you do your thrive list. So do that off your bank statements. Now, what you can then start to figure out is where your spending is. And the reason Starling is so great for that is exactly like you said you can set up these amazing little sub accounts called spaces so we did the exercise went through everything and we've got a space for kids
左边写下你需要生存的东西。也就是你的固定成本、账单、抵押贷款、汽车保险、房屋保险、食物等等。右边写下你的“繁荣清单”。根据你的银行对账单来做。现在，你可以开始弄清楚你的支出在哪里了。Starling之所以这么棒，正是因为你刚才说的，你可以设置这些神奇的小子账户，称为“空间（Spaces）”。所以我们做了这个练习，检查了一切，我们为孩子设置了一个空间，
haircuts school uniform when the dog needs a groom car problems so if there's any problems with the car we've got a one called hit the Fan Fund because there's always some little expenses that just pop up. We've got kids' pocket money. I was trying to save up for a set of gold clubs, but that's gone out the window now, so that's disappeared. But what I love is that we worked our expenditure out over the year, so we knew that the MOTs were going to come for the car. So we knew that in, I think it was March, they're going to come through. As the cars get a bit older, there's probably going to be a little bit more. So every month, something goes into that space.
理发、校服、狗狗美容、汽车维修。所以如果汽车有任何问题，我们有一个叫“突发状况基金（Hit the Fan Fund）”的空间，因为总会有一些小开支突然冒出来。我们有孩子的零花钱。我本来想存钱买一套高尔夫球杆，但现在没戏了，所以那个空间消失了。但我喜欢的是，我们计算了一年的支出，所以我们知道汽车的MOT（年检）要来了。所以我们知道，我想是在三月，它们会到来。随着车龄增长，可能开支会多一点。所以每个月，都会有钱存入那个空间。
And you can name the space whatever you want. You can put a picture of whatever you want on there as well. So every time you open your app, you build an engagement. And I think one of the things when you talk about budget planning and managing your finances a lot of people think it's really restrictive and it can feel like if you've never done that before as in you just go out and tap your card away willy-nilly to do whatever you like with it but by having those spaces it's exactly the opposite the first the first or the second month that had happened we kind of got to the end of the month,
你可以给空间命名，也可以在上面放任何你想要的图片。所以每次你打开应用程序，你都会建立一种参与感。我认为当你谈论预算规划和管理财务时，很多人认为这非常受限。如果你以前从未这样做过，只是随意刷卡消费，那确实会感觉受限。但有了这些空间，情况恰恰相反。第一个或第二个个月，我们到了月底，
looked down at the accounts and panicked because we thought there must have been a direct debit that hasn't come out. There's something gone out that we're not aware about. Went back through, looked through the statements and it was the opposite because we knew everything was covered. So what it means moving forward now is when the kids need some school shoes, when the kids need their football fees,
看着账户，感到恐慌，因为我们以为肯定有一笔直接借记没扣除。肯定有什么我们不知道的支出。回去检查对账单，结果恰恰相反，因为我们知道一切都已覆盖。所以这意味着未来，当孩子们需要校鞋，当孩子们需要足球费时，
it's all there ready to go. So you're not having those one-off expenses. And it's, like you just said there, Marion, it's so powerful having that functionality built into the accounts. That's why I love those accounts and talk to everyone about them. But it also kind of makes me wonder why that wasn't done much sooner with some of the traditional stuff. Potentially life-changing stuff.
一切都准备好了。所以你不会有那些一次性的意外开支。就像你刚才说的，Marianne，在账户中内置这种功能太强大了。这就是为什么我喜欢这些账户并向每个人推荐它们。但这也让我纳闷，为什么传统的银行没有早点这样做。这可能是改变生活的东西。
But what we know about humans as well ian is we don't always love change do we and we can feel a sense of loyalty and kind of traditional and i have changed my bank account so i originally was with hsbc until it got to the stage where i thought they're not even giving me interest i'm not having i'm leaving and so i moved and i went to halifax and then originally they had a reward account and it was quite good and it got worse and worse and worse until it I think they disbanded it at all I'm not having it I'm cross I'm leaving and I moved and I went to Barclays and I've been with Barclays ever since and theirs is getting ever so slightly less good over time in terms of their rewards but I'm still as I'm listening to you thinking yes that
但我们也知道人类并不总是喜欢改变，对吧？我们可能会感到一种忠诚感和传统感。我确实换过银行账户，我最初用的是汇丰银行，直到我发现他们甚至不给我利息，我受不了了，我要离开。所以我转到了哈利法克斯，起初他们有一个奖励账户，还不错，但后来变得越来越差，直到我想他们完全取消了它。我受不了了，我很生气，我要离开。我转到了巴克莱银行，从那以后我一直用巴克莱。随着时间的推移，他们的奖励也变得越来越少，但我听着你说话，心想：是的，
does sound good I already do all that in the background with an excel spreadsheet but actually it's better if it's done for me because then nothing's going to slip through the radar but also i'm thinking can i be bothered to change it you know because we can be quite lazy creatures of habit but that can cost us can't it oh like huge like not just on your bank account like if you think about your gas and electricity your car insurance the those fixed costs every single month companies make a massive amount of money from inertia by us just sitting there and not making changes and not being on top of this stuff and the bank account is one of the big big things so there's a there's a bank account switch guarantee in place where if you switch your bank account everything should be moved from one account to the other i think it's 14 days it used to be 28
这听起来确实不错。我已经在Excel表格里后台做了所有这些，但如果能自动完成其实更好，这样就不会有任何遗漏。但我也在想，我有动力去换吗？你知道，因为我们可能是相当懒惰的习惯性生物，但这可能会让我们付出代价，对吧？哦，代价巨大。不仅仅是银行账户，如果你想想你的燃气和电费、汽车保险，那些每个月的固定成本，公司通过我们的惯性赚取了大量的钱，因为我们只是坐在那里，不做出改变，不掌控这些事情。银行账户是其中非常重要的一项。有一个“银行账户切换保证”机制，如果你切换银行账户，一切都应该从一个账户转移到另一个账户，我想是14天，以前是28天。
certainly when i worked in banking and it was a little bit fraught at the start because there'd be a direct debit missed or something and you get a late payment charge but the bank would always compensate you for that now it's just ultra slick like within when we moved our bank account across the stone i think within within day, we got confirmation from them that all the direct debits were set up. They transferred all of the standing orders across. They transferred even your existing PEs, so people that you've made a payment to in the past, all there.
当然，当我在银行工作时，刚开始有点紧张，因为可能会错过直接借记或类似的事情，你会收到滞纳金，但银行总是会补偿你。现在它非常顺滑。当我们把银行账户转到Starling时，我想在一天之内，我们就收到了他们的确认，所有的直接借记都设置好了。他们转移了所有的常设指令，甚至转移了你现有的收款人，也就是你过去付款的人，都在那里。
It was absolutely seamless, but it's one of those things where you think, ah, well, I get the insurance, or I get cover for my phone, or I get this. Great, that's good. It's some good benefits. But why are they offering you those benefits? Because you're paying for them. You pay for those benefits, like the money that you go into the bank and you put into your bank account and they lend out at a higher percentage or they do something else with it. It's a fractional banking system, it's called. Now, if you move that to an account that works for you, forget about the additional an account that works for you forget about the additional benefits that works for you and makes you aware of your spending you can see on screen
这绝对是无缝衔接的。但这是那种你会想“啊，我得到了保险，或者我得到了手机保障，或者我得到了这个”的事情。很好，这不错。有一些好的福利。但他们为什么要提供这些福利？因为你在为它们付费。你支付这些福利，就像你存入银行账户的钱，他们以更高的利率借出，或者用它做其他事情。这被称为部分准备金银行制度。现在，如果你把它转到一个为你服务的账户，别管那些额外的福利，
how much you've spent on amazon this month you could see that you've got money for the mot you've got money for the kids uniform all that stuff that is more worth a lot more than 10 pound a month for your phone cover or whatever it is and i can encourage anybody to have a look at that stuff and really get your head into it because it's like it's a game changer and i don't use that word very lightly but it is it's phenomenal once you get a handle on that i guess i was just thinking then you know what's the worst that could happen i could change and if i don't like it, I could move back, couldn't I? Yep.
一个为你服务并让你意识到支出的账户，你可以在屏幕上看到你这个月在亚马逊上花了多少钱，你可以看到你有钱支付MOT，你有钱支付孩子的校服，所有这些东西的价值远高于每月10英镑的手机保险或其他什么。我鼓励任何人去看看这些东西，真正深入了解它，因为这改变了游戏规则，我不会轻易使用这个词，但它确实是。一旦你掌握了它，它就是现象级的。我想我刚才在想，最坏的情况会怎样？我可以换，如果我不喜欢，我可以换回来，对吧？是的。
100%. I mean, you don't necessarily even need to change lock, stock, and barrel. You could just open one of these accounts. I mean, what I'd encourage anybody that listens to this podcast is, certainly in the UK, there will be other equivalents outside of the UK. I think Chase over in the States do something similar. It's to just go into Google or YouTube, sorry, and type in Starling bank account demonstration, Monzo bank account demonstration. And there's a little video that just explains how it all works and what to do.
百分之百。我的意思是，你不一定非要彻底更换。你可以先开一个这样的账户。我的意思是，我鼓励任何收听这个播客的人，当然是在英国，英国以外会有其他等价物。我想美国的Chase银行也做类似的事情。只需去谷歌或YouTube，搜索“Starling银行账户演示”、“Monzo银行账户演示”。有一个小视频解释了它是如何工作的以及该怎么做。
You could just go and set an account up and just get a little feel for it and see how it works first before you make the switch across and if you then decide to switch over awesome it's done you can do it you can dip your toe in with the stuff and if you don't like it like you've said close the account go back to where you were and be stuck in your old ways the good thing about my current account though is that I have got a bespoke card with a picture of me and my husband on our wedding day in it. Like, that's nice. That's difficult to take out my wallet, you know? Yeah, of course it is. Absolutely.
你可以先设置一个账户，在切换之前先感受一下它是如何工作的。如果你决定切换，太棒了，完成了。你可以先试水，如果你不喜欢，就像你说的，关闭账户，回到原来的地方，继续你旧的方式。不过我目前的账户好的一点是，我有一张定制卡，上面有我和我丈夫婚礼当天的照片。这很好。那很难从我的钱包里拿出来，你知道吗？是的，当然。绝对是。
But I think over time, like, most places will do that now. Like, I loved that when the Barclays stuff came out because there was a guy that I work with at the same time that came in and had a picture of his son on it. And it was so cute. Like, he got his card out and he loved it. it like his whole face lit up whenever he got that card out of his wallet i think it was such a great idea by them lovely so i could talk about i could talk money all day i think this is a great topic to be talking about but many of our audience listening today might well be working in public um public sector i said they might well be working in public um public sector so they might well be working for the nhs um and often with that there's a there's a pension that comes as part of it is that going to be
但我认为随着时间的推移，大多数地方现在都会这样做。当巴克莱推出这个功能时，我非常喜欢，因为当时和我一起工作的一个同事进来，上面有他儿子的照片。太可爱了。他拿出卡时非常喜欢。每次他从钱包里拿出那张卡，他的整张脸都亮了起来。我认为这是他们想出的一个好主意。太好了，我可以整天谈论金钱，我认为这是一个很好的话题。但今天收听的许多听众可能在公共部门工作，比如在NHS工作。通常情况下，这会附带一份养老金。那足够了吗？
enough should we be considering having a private pension in addition to that let's have a little chat about pensions yeah hot topic especially at the moment especially when you look at what's recently happened with the with the budget and the conservative government lifting the cap on um how much it can pay in a lifetime but i suppose that's more of the top end of the kind of nhs where you've got the the bigger consultants kind of stepping away but if you kind of look at the the lifeblood of the kind of health service and the people, like you say, sit in these bands that we talked about at the start, it's a real. There's no hard and fast answer is probably the simple way to look at it because it depends on a much bigger picture. And one of the things that I'll always talk to clients around is the first question I'll ask is, what do they want to get out of the process?
我们是否应该考虑额外购买私人养老金？让我们聊聊养老金。是的，热门话题，尤其是在当下。特别是当你看看最近预算案中发生的事情，保守党政府取消了终身养老金缴存上限。但这更多是针对NHS的高层，那些即将退休的资深顾问。但如果你看看医疗服务的核心，那些处于我们开头谈到的职级中的人，这是一个现实。没有硬性的答案，这可能是最简单的看法，因为它取决于更大的图景。我总是与客户讨论的一件事是，我问的第一个问题是：他们想从这个过程中得到什么？
Like what, what makes the time that we're going to spend together valuable and ask yourself that same question. Like if you're about to go on the exercise of thinking, right, we need to look big picture stuff. Like what does our retirement look like? What are the next five, 10 or 15 years? There are a series of questions that you can just ask yourself to really uncover what's important to you. Now, does a pension play a big part in that? And I think certainly the financial services industry over the years, we've put a massive amount of pressure on people to have a pension. And I think they are very tax efficient. They're a great way to save for your future, but they aren't right for everybody. Because you might have a partner that is a significant level of income. So you might not need that level of income. You might have buy to let property. You
就像什么让我们将要共度的时间变得有价值？问自己同样的问题。如果你正准备开始思考：好吧，我们需要着眼于大局。退休生活是什么样的？未来5年、10年或15年是什么样的？有一系列问题你可以问自己，真正发现对你来说什么是重要的。养老金在其中起很大作用吗？我认为金融服务行业多年来确实给人们施加了巨大的压力去购买养老金。我认为它们非常节税，是为未来储蓄的好方法，但它们并不适合所有人。因为你可能有一个收入水平很高的伴侣，所以你可能不需要那种水平的收入。你可能有出租房产。你
might be further down the line and decide you want to downsize the property to give you some equity to be able to fund that retirement. So rather than just think about a pension, what I'll encourage anybody to do is to think about ideal scenario, what does your retirement look like? And I think if you focus on the numbers, it becomes really transactional and it can feel really boring as well, because I don't like talking about the numbers and that can feel strange for a financial advisor, right? But my focus is on the important stuff. So it's going to be about what does that retirement look like? And we'll even go so far as to think, well, if you want to retire in Spain and go and live out there, why?
可能在人生阶段更靠后，决定缩小住房规模，以获得一些资产来资助退休。所以，与其只考虑养老金，我鼓励任何人去思考理想的场景：你的退休生活是什么样的？我认为如果你专注于数字，它会变得非常交易化，也会让人觉得很无聊。因为我不喜欢谈论数字，这对于财务顾问来说可能听起来很奇怪，对吧？但我的重点是重要的事情。所以它将关于退休生活是什么样的。我们甚至会深入思考，如果你想在西班牙退休并住在那里，为什么？
Where? Who with? When do you want to do it? Why, why, why, why, why? And paint that picture, like almost paint the villa, paint that scenario in your head, like what's it going to look like getting up every morning and going and having breakfast on your terrace, going down to the beach, all that stuff. And once you get that emotional engagement and you can really paint that picture, the numbers can almost become secondary to that
在哪里？和谁一起？你想什么时候做？为什么，为什么，为什么？描绘那幅图景，几乎在脑海中画出那栋别墅，画出那个场景。想象一下每天早上起床，在露台上吃早餐，去海滩，所有这些事情。一旦你有了这种情感参与，并且你真的能描绘出那幅图景，数字几乎就变得次要了，
and just almost fall into place. Because rather than sitting down with your financial advisor once a year and saying, all right, Maria, you need to be putting 300 pound a month into your pension every month and you're like well where am i going to find that it's okay if you want this villa in spain to happen we need to make some changes and those changes are going to be this you will probably find a way to make that happen more than you need to put 300 pound a month into your pension ultimately the result's the same. And kind of going back to what you're saying, should people have private pensions as
几乎会自然而然地到位。因为与其每年和你的财务顾问坐下来一次，说：“好吧，Marianne，你每个月需要往养老金里存300英镑。”而你却想：“我从哪找这笔钱？”如果这个西班牙别墅的愿景能实现，我们需要做出一些改变，这些改变将是这样的。你可能会找到一种方法来实现它，而不是仅仅为了往养老金里存300英镑。最终结果是一样的。回到你刚才说的，人们是否应该有私人养老金
well as the NHS one? I mean, I think for years, the NHS has been an exceptional pension scheme. I still think it's an exceptional pension scheme compared to whatever else is out there. And boys, start with a simple fact of can you afford to do it? Realistically, can you afford to put more money in your pension whilst balancing out what you need right now, what you're going to need in the next five to 10 years? Because ultimately your pension, you can't touch out of your 55 anyway. That will be 57 before you know it.
以及NHS的养老金？我的意思是，我认为多年来，NHS一直是一个卓越的养老金计划。与现有的其他计划相比，我仍然认为它是一个卓越的养老金计划。伙计们，从一个简单的事实开始：你负担得起吗？现实地讲，你负担得起在平衡你现在需要的东西、未来5到10年需要的东西的同时，往养老金里投入更多的钱吗？因为最终你的养老金，无论如何你55岁之前都碰不到。等你意识到的时候，那已经是57岁了。
That will be 60 much quicker, certainly by the time we get there. That money's away for a long, long time. That's the million-dollar question. It's like a set of scales like almost three scales it's the short medium and the long term and the pensions the long term stuff the medium is five years the short term is like what do you need right now if your washing machine blows up it's a it's a real balance of that like i said there's no hard and fast answer to it yeah i feel like i wish I'd known you in 2000 and whenever it was. I was in 2006, I think it was. So I'd started in a private, private hospital. And at that point, they weren't inviting new members of staff to come into the pension scheme until after three months.
那会很快变成60岁，肯定在我们到达那里的时候。那笔钱要存很长很长一段时间。这是百万美元的问题。它就像一套天平，几乎有三个天平：短期、中期和长期。养老金是长期的东西，中期是五年，短期是你现在需要什么。如果你的洗衣机坏了，这确实是一个平衡问题。就像我说的，没有硬性的答案。是的，我觉得我真希望我在2000年或无论什么时候认识你。我想是2006年。当时我在一家私立医院。那时，他们直到三个月后才邀请新员工加入养老金计划。
But I think initially I was on a six-month fixed term contract and so when it came up and they invited me to join I thought well there's probably no point because I'll be out before you know it you know if I can't get a new job but they did renew my contract and actually I ended up working there for almost two years and I never got around to joining the pension scheme and And still, I think that was probably quite a stupid decision on my part because I didn't have any fixed overheads. I was living with my parents. I was earning a reasonable wage. And I still think that was like wasted money for my future. Should we be talking these decisions through with people 100 if you look at it as
但我认为最初我签的是六个月的固定期限合同，所以当机会来临时，他们邀请我加入，我想：“好吧，可能没意义，因为我很快就会离开。”你知道，如果我找不到新工作的话。但他们确实续签了我的合同，实际上我最终在那里工作了近两年，我一直没抽出时间加入养老金计划。而且，我仍然认为那可能是我做出的一个相当愚蠢的决定，因为我没有任何固定开支。我和父母住在一起。我赚着合理的工资。我仍然认为那对我未来的钱来说是浪费。我们是否应该和别人讨论这些决定？百分之百，如果你把它看作是
at a very simple level like people look at the word pension i think boring that's going to be years away before i'm going to especially if you're in your 20s right and you're at the point where you think well i'll i'll do that later in 17 years of experience in financial services, the people that retire at 55 are the ones that started it then. And you're not talking massive amounts. You're not talking huge commitments. But think about it this way. The minimum requirement for a pension now
从一个非常简单的层面来看，人们看到“养老金”这个词时会觉得很无聊，认为那是多年以后的事，尤其是如果你才20多岁，你会觉得以后再说吧。但在金融服务领域拥有17年经验的我看来，那些55岁退休的人，正是从那个年纪就开始规划的人。这并不需要巨额资金，也不需要巨大的承诺。但请这样想：现在养老金的最低要求是
as a workplace scheme is an 8% contribution. So you put in 5%, your employer will put in 3%. On top of that, you'll get your tax relief. So if you get, as a basic rate tax pay, say 20% tax relief, then you're almost doubling your money before anything else happens because you've got your employer contribution and your tax relief. So right off the bat, you put in 100 quid,
作为工作场所计划，缴费比例为8%。你自己投入5%，雇主投入3%。除此之外，你还能获得税收减免。因此，如果你作为基本税率纳税人，获得20%的税收减免，那么在其他任何事情发生之前，你的钱几乎翻了一番，因为你既有雇主的缴费，又有税收减免。所以一开始，你投入100英镑，
you're effectively getting nearly £200 into that pension. It's not quite that, but it's there or thereabouts. Where else are you going to get that? Where else are you going to get that? And if you did that in your 20s, or maybe even you've got kids and you started doing that for them, because you can do a pension for your kids from birth. If you did that for them, they're the ones that will continue paying 150 quid a month into the pension for the rest of their life and retire early or get to 65 with a whacking great pension rather than have to get which the vast majority of people do get to the 40s hit the panic button and i'm doing the same hit the panic button and think i need to start plowing some serious money into this pension or
实际上你的养老金账户里就有了近200英镑。虽然不完全是这样，但也差不多了。你还能从哪里获得这样的回报？如果你在20多岁时这样做，或者你有了孩子并开始为他们这样做，因为你可以从孩子出生起就为他们开设养老金账户。如果你为他们做了这些，他们就是那些余生每月继续向养老金账户存入150英镑，并能提前退休或在65岁时拥有一笔巨额养老金的人，而不是像绝大多数人那样，到了40多岁才按下恐慌按钮——我也在做同样的事——按下恐慌按钮，认为我需要开始往这个养老金里投入大量资金，否则
i'm never going to be able to retire and i was was the same as you. I just didn't have one. I worked in banking where the pension schemes were really good. It wasn't even an interest to me at the time. And then I had kids young at 23. It was then, right, can I put money into a pension or can I afford to, I guess, kind of pay for stuff for the kids? But look back and reflect on it. there was always money for a coffee there's probably always money for a beer with me mates it's a tough one to balance because you've kind of you want to enjoy yourself right it's not all about money like your
我永远无法退休。我曾经和你一样。我当时根本没有养老金。我在银行工作，那里的养老金计划非常好。当时我甚至对此不感兴趣。后来我在23岁时早早有了孩子。那时我在想，我是该把钱存入养老金，还是负担得起为孩子们买东西？但回过头来反思，我总是有钱买咖啡，也总是有钱和朋友喝啤酒。这很难平衡，因为你想要享受生活，对吧？生活不仅仅是关于钱，你的
life your life shouldn't all be about money and focusing on this stuff and and thinking that i need x amount to be able to have a great life when I retire. And if I don't have that, I'm a failure. The vast majority of people get to the forties and then start really putting that foot down and thinking, right, I need to put in 500, 600 pound a month. That's vast majority of clients that I deal with do that because they just haven't had that foresight. So you're not alone. It's not too late if you haven't started a pension in your thirties to start then even your 40s even your 50s but if you can start it in your 20s get your kids to start theirs in their 20s and make them more aware of it and i
生活不应该完全围绕着金钱，不应该只关注这些东西，认为我需要多少钱才能在退休时过上好生活。如果我没有达到那个目标，我就是个失败者。绝大多数人到了40多岁才开始真正发力，认为我需要每月投入500、600英镑。我接触的绝大多数客户都是这样做的，因为他们之前缺乏这种远见。所以你并不孤单。如果你在30多岁还没开始存养老金，现在开始也不晚，甚至40多岁、50多岁开始都可以。但如果你能在20多岁就开始，让你的孩子也在20多岁开始，让他们更有意识，而且我
think what's quite interesting now is we've got generations of people kind of coming through the system and the education system who are of the instagram generation they are of social media they're seeing all this amazing content from financial coaches financial advisors ways to make money and they're a lot more aware of this stuff and i think you've got a generation of kids certainly a lot of them coming up that are much more financially aware than we ever were because it's all there but the other side of that is that it's a lot easier for them to get money and buy things that they don't necessarily need it's a real kind of again balancing act i wish i'd done it sooner i wish i'd been less embarrassed i was embarrassed about not having enough money i wouldn't have thought i had enough
认为现在非常有趣的是，我们有几代人通过教育系统成长起来，他们是Instagram一代，是社交媒体一代。他们看到了来自理财教练、理财顾问的各种精彩内容，以及赚钱的方法，他们对这些事情的了解要多得多。我认为你们这一代孩子，当然有很多正在成长起来的孩子，比我们当时更具理财意识，因为信息触手可及。但另一方面，他们也更容易获得金钱并购买他们不一定需要的东西。这确实是一种平衡。我希望我能早点做，我希望我当时没那么尴尬。我曾因为没有足够的钱而感到尴尬，我不会认为我有足够的
money to talk to a financial advisor when I was on band four, five, six. But actually, when I look back now, I didn't have a child until 2013. In my early 30s, I had so much disposable income before I committed to a mortgage and stuff that that was probably my most abundant time in my life. So I went from band four to band six. And I went from, you know, I was only paying about 300 pounds a month at that point. I remember looking in my bank account on the day that I've got my first full month's pay of band six. And I was like, oh, my God, that is so much money to me. But didn't have kids and so this would have been a really excellent time for me to think about starting some investments even though it felt embarrassing
钱去咨询理财顾问，当时我处于Band 4、5、6的工资水平。但实际上，当我回首往事时，我在2013年才有了孩子。在我30岁出头时，在承担抵押贷款等责任之前，我有大量的可支配收入，那可能是我一生中最富裕的时期。所以我从Band 4升到了Band 6。我记得当时我每月只支付大约300英镑。我记得在我拿到Band 6第一个月全额工资的那天，我查看了我的银行账户。我当时想，天哪，这对我来说是一大笔钱。但我当时没有孩子，所以那对我来说是一个考虑开始投资的绝佳时机，尽管当时感觉很尴尬，
and a bit dirty and a bit like shame filled i get it it's completely normal because there's a real perception in the financial services industry of the financial services industry that you need to have a lot of money to sit down and have these conversations with a financial advisor. Now, my view on it is I would have a conversation with anybody about financial advice and money. It doesn't necessarily mean that we're going to become a client and work together because I'm also running a business. There's a cost involved for doing that. But that doesn't mean that I can't help you make some of those decisions. And I think when you look at like the FinTech that's out there, some of the apps to kind of get you started.
有点难为情，甚至有点羞耻感。我明白，这完全正常，因为在金融服务行业，人们有一种根深蒂固的观念，认为你需要有很多钱才能坐下来与理财顾问进行这些对话。现在，我的观点是，我愿意与任何人讨论理财建议和金钱问题。这并不一定意味着我们会成为客户并合作，因为我也在经营一家企业。这样做是有成本的。但这并不意味着我不能帮助你做出一些决定。我认为当你看看现有的金融科技，以及一些让你入门的应用程序时，
Starling's a great one to kind of manage your money. You've then got things like Moneybox. You've then got Circa 5000. These are entry-level ways to get in. Whereas historically, you wouldn't be able to do that. That stuff didn't exist when you were probably having your kids. When you had all that money, they just weren't there. How would you have done it? And I think there's a perception of a financial advisor to be in a gray suit, driving a drag and not really interested in you
Starling是一个管理资金的好工具。你还有像Moneybox这样的东西。你还有Circa 5000。这些都是入门级的途径。而在过去，你无法做到这一点。当你可能生孩子的时候，这些东西根本不存在。当你拥有所有那些钱时，它们只是不存在。你会怎么做？我认为人们对理财顾问的印象是穿着灰色西装，开着捷豹，除非你有20万英镑，否则他们对你作为一个人并不真正感兴趣。
as a person, unless you've got 200 grand. Part of the challenge we've got is the average age of a financial advisor in the industry is 58. And those guys are going to be coming out of the industry in the next five, 10 years or so, which leaves a massive gap. There aren't enough people coming in at the bottom end. I think technology's got a big part to play and that's to service some of those people that need help but i think a lot of um that experience disappears a lot of the expertise goes and the financial advisors that are left will effectively be able
我们面临的挑战之一是行业内理财顾问的平均年龄是58岁。这些人将在未来5到10年内退出该行业，这留下了一个巨大的缺口。底层没有足够的新人进入。我认为技术在服务那些需要帮助的人方面发挥了重要作用，但我认为很多那种经验正在消失，很多专业知识正在流失，剩下的理财顾问将有效地能够
to cherry pick their clients and i think it becomes more challenging for people to get financial advice because as that market shrinks, which it is doing, then you can effectively pick who you're dealing with. And that price point might be nearly £200,000. So unless you've got £200,000, you might not be able to have a conversation with an F8. Now, that's just my opinion, but I know others in the industry share that as well. I think there's a big gap. There's still time to address it and how people can get that information
挑选他们的客户。我认为人们获得理财建议变得更具挑战性，因为随着市场萎缩，你可以有效地选择与谁打交道。那个价格门槛可能接近20万英镑。所以除非你有20万英镑，否则你可能无法与理财顾问交谈。这只是我的观点，但我知道业内其他人也认同这一点。我认为存在一个巨大的缺口。还有时间来解决这个问题，以及人们如何获得这些信息
and have access to it. And a lot of the time, it can feel like information overload. Like if you're not necessarily financially literate, like you understand how a pension works, you understand how a bank account or an investment or a savings account works, then how are you then going to be able
并获得访问权限。很多时候，这会让人感到信息过载。如果你不一定具备金融素养，比如你不了解养老金是如何运作的，不了解银行账户、投资或储蓄账户是如何运作的，那么你将如何能够
to take that to the next level? You'll probably spend a bit of time looking on the internet, doing some research, looking at YouTube, account works then how are you then going to be able to take that to the next level you probably spend a bit of time looking on the internet doing some research looking at youtube but how do you separate the wheat from the chaff what's the good stuff and what is absolutely nonsense because let's be honest there's a lot of nonsense out there as well um like i think we've got a big responsibility as an industry to do more to to help people make better financial decisions. That's certainly what I want to do. And you're doing it well.
将其提升到一个新的水平？你可能会花点时间在互联网上搜索，做一些研究，看YouTube，但你如何去粗取精？什么是好的东西，什么是绝对的胡说八道？因为老实说，外面也有很多胡说八道。我认为作为一个行业，我们有很大的责任做更多的事情来帮助人们做出更好的财务决策。这当然是我想要做的。你做得很好。
So I feel like I learn a lot from following you on LinkedIn, definitely. And that's definitely what people should do, isn't it? How could they find you on LinkedIn? Just stick my name into LinkedIn, Ian Dempsey. I don't have a website. That'll probably come at some point in the future. I just, well, I mean, when you first get going in business, you just need to get the wheels turning first.
所以我感觉通过在LinkedIn上关注你，我学到了很多，确实如此。这绝对是人们应该做的，不是吗？他们怎么能在LinkedIn上找到你？只要在LinkedIn上输入我的名字，Ian Dempsey。我没有网站。那可能在未来的某个时候会出现。我只是，嗯，我的意思是，当你刚开始创业时，你只需要先让轮子转起来。
And there's so many decisions to make. The thing for me was right. LinkedIn works. I know it works. I spent a lot of time on there. I'm going to carry on doing what I'm doing on there. It's educational stuff. It's helping people make better financial decisions.
而且有太多的决定要做。对我来说，事情就是这样。LinkedIn有效。我知道它有效。我在上面花了很多时间。我将继续在上面做我正在做的事情。这是教育性的内容。这是在帮助人们做出更好的财务决策。
That's where i am linkedin just put ian dempsey in and this face will come up and you'll be able to see me on there and see what i'm all about and honestly i do i'm not even just saying it i feel like i've learned a lot and you you pose really thought-provoking questions and ideas that do make me stop and think. And, you know, the idea and even the word wealth, you know, it's safe to say the word wealth and to think about how wealthy you might want to be one day. That's okay, isn't it? It's safe. Of course it is. Like, I mean, people kind of dismiss it and say, like, well well i could be dead in two years time you might be but you might live for another 60 years and do you really want to be worrying
这就是我的所在，LinkedIn，只要输入Ian Dempsey，这张脸就会出现，你就能在上面看到我，了解我的一切。老实说，我真的不是在客套，我觉得我学到了很多，你提出了非常发人深省的问题和想法，确实让我停下来思考。而且，你知道，这个想法，甚至“财富”这个词，你知道，可以说“财富”这个词，并思考你有一天可能想变得多富有。这没关系，不是吗？这很安全。当然是。我的意思是，人们会否定它，说，嗯，我可能两年后就死了。你可能会，但你也可能再活60年，你真的想担心
about whether you can turn the heat in them because you can't afford it and i think wealth means it's a it's a word that's very powerful it's very emotive and it stirs up emotions in different people like even the people that are listening to this now will have that word wealth would have instantly painted an image it did for me as soon as you mentioned it paints an image in your head about what wealth looks like but everybody's wealthy in lots of different ways like it doesn't necessarily have to be financially it's it's about finding what's important to you and how you kind of kind of move to get there and building some financial wealth to help you get there so important and i think education system's got a point to play part to play in that which is which is starting to happen which is amazing um it's it's about education helping
关于你是否能负担得起暖气费吗？我认为财富是一个非常强大、非常感性的词，它在不同的人心中激起不同的情绪。即使是现在正在听这个节目的人，听到“财富”这个词也会立刻浮现出一个形象。你提到它时，我脑海中也浮现出了一个形象，关于财富看起来是什么样子的。但每个人在很多方面都是富有的，它不一定非要是经济上的。这是关于找到对你来说重要的事情，以及你如何朝着那个目标前进，并建立一些财务财富来帮助你实现目标，这非常重要。我认为教育系统在其中发挥了一定的作用，这正在开始发生，这太棒了。这是关于教育帮助
people kind of make better decisions i think exactly like you said you've learned something from the stuff that i put out there it's a lot of of jargon out there. There's a lot of kind of smoke and mirrors for a lot of organisations. Not intentionally, I think, to a certain extent, the regulator's got a part to play in that in terms of simplifying the information that goes out there. But I also understand that advisors run businesses. They need to make money. They need to be able to feed their family.
人们做出更好的决定。我认为正如你所说，你从我发布的内容中学到了一些东西。外面有很多行话。对于许多组织来说，有很多烟雾弹。我认为在某种程度上，监管机构在简化发布的信息方面发挥了一定的作用。但我同时也理解顾问们是在经营企业。他们需要赚钱。他们需要养家糊口。
So it's a tough one it's a tough one to balance out it is and many of the people listening to the podcast will be working directly with people supporting their mental health um and when it comes to benefits and you know there not being enough money to go around and things being fair or not fair um is citizens advice bureau still a thing is that still somewhere we can direct people to get, you know, reputable advice, Ian? Yeah, absolutely. I think they do a great job. I guess the challenge is they're a charity, so they're a voluntary organisation. They offer debt counselling services. Trying to get an appointment with them might be a challenge because there are a lot of
所以这是一个很难平衡的问题。确实如此。许多收听播客的人将直接与支持其心理健康的人一起工作。当涉及到福利，你知道，没有足够的钱，事情是否公平，公民咨询局（Citizens Advice Bureau）还是一个机构吗？那仍然是一个我们可以引导人们去获得可靠建议的地方吗，Ian？是的，绝对是。我认为他们做得很好。我想挑战在于他们是一个慈善机构，所以他们是一个志愿者组织。他们提供债务咨询服务。试图与他们预约可能是一个挑战，因为有很多
people struggling at the moment, but they are there to help. And what you'll find is that there's a really great structured programme that these volunteers go through with Citizens Advice to be able to sit down in front of you and to give you the help and support for money. And what happens in the vast majority of occasions is these guys are maybe at the tail end of their career or they've worked with in those particular sectors they've got an incredible
人目前正在挣扎，但他们确实在那里提供帮助。你会发现，这些志愿者在公民咨询局经历了一个非常好的结构化项目，能够坐在你面前，为你提供金钱方面的帮助和支持。在绝大多数情况下，这些人可能处于职业生涯的末期，或者他们在特定的行业工作过，他们拥有令人难以置信的
amount of knowledge that can give you help and support so reach out to these people there's another one which is um christians against poverty it's the same similar thing to citizens advice you don't necessarily have to have christian beliefs to be able to reach out for support but they can certainly um help guide you in the right direction um that there's loads and loads of information out there as well british gas and some of the banking organizations as well had i think started saying recently you don't need to be one of our customers to call us and talk about you know not having enough money or fuel poverty and stuff like that. Is that anything you know about?
知识，可以为你提供帮助和支持。所以去联系这些人。还有另一个组织叫“基督徒反贫困”（Christians Against Poverty），它和公民咨询局类似。你不一定非要有基督教信仰才能寻求支持，但他们肯定可以帮助引导你走上正确的方向。外面也有大量的信息。英国天然气公司和一些银行机构最近也开始说，你不需要成为我们的客户就可以打电话给我们，谈论没有足够的钱或燃料贫困等问题。这是你知道的吗？
Yeah, absolutely they do. Like I think they're starting to kind of take stock of where their responsibility lies and how to help support people through difficult times. Because let's be honest, in this country, we're all in it together. Like we've all felt the pinch and felt the squeeze over the last couple of years and things have got more expensive.
是的，绝对是。我认为他们开始盘点自己的责任所在，以及如何帮助支持人们度过困难时期。因为老实说，在这个国家，我们都在同一条船上。在过去几年里，我们都感受到了压力和紧缩，东西变得更贵了。
The shopping costs a lot more more the supermarket shelves are empty sometimes when you go in there that didn't happen 10 years ago i think about five years ago but those banks can help and and it's go back like one of the first things we talked about marianne which was burying your head in the sand go and have those conversations with people as difficult as those conversations might feel for you the people that you sit in front of will have heard that a hundred times before like there wasn't anything within banking when i certainly worked there that shocked me in terms of financials because i'll have heard it all before and if you've heard it all before there'll be a route to help like again don't bury your head in the sand if you need help and support there's help and support out there citizens advice are great your bank is great
购物成本高了很多，超市货架有时是空的，10年前并没有发生这种情况，我想大约是5年前。但那些银行可以提供帮助，让我们回到我们谈论的第一件事，Marianne，那就是不要掩耳盗铃。去和人们进行那些对话，尽管这些对话对你来说可能感觉很困难。你面对的人以前已经听过一百次了。当我还在银行工作时，在财务方面没有什么让我感到震惊的，因为我以前都听过。如果你以前都听过，就会有解决办法。再次强调，不要掩耳盗铃。如果你需要帮助和支持，外面有帮助和支持。公民咨询局很棒，你的银行也很棒，
christians against poverty are great there are other charities out there that can help as well and i think the conversation around money needs to be a lot more fluid than it needs to be talk to your family talk to your friends it's not rude having these conversations like you're not you're not having conversations about how much do you earn and what do you spend your money on? It's like, look, John, I'm in a little bit of debt. I don't know what to do. Is there anything that you would suggest?
“基督徒反贫困”很棒，还有其他慈善机构也可以提供帮助。我认为关于金钱的对话需要比现在更流畅。和你的家人谈谈，和你的朋友谈谈。进行这些对话并不粗鲁。你不是在谈论你赚多少钱，你把钱花在什么地方。而是说，看，John，我欠了一点债。我不知道该怎么办。你有什么建议吗？
Then have those conversations. Any of your friends that are your close friends would be happy to help you. That's not necessarily lending your money to dig you out of a hole. That is, well, do you know what, John? I've been there and done it. I've never talked to anybody else about it, hole that is well do you know what john i've been there and done it i've never talked to anybody else about it but this is what i've done in the past that conversation needs to be a lot more open than it currently is priceless information there ian thank you so much for taking the time to talk to us about this really important stuff and people as i said should definitely be
然后进行这些对话。你任何亲密的朋友都会很乐意帮助你。这不一定是指借钱给你帮你脱困。而是说，你知道吗，John？我经历过，也做过。我从来没有和别人谈过这件事，但我过去就是这么做的。这种对话需要比现在更开放。Ian，那里有无价的信息，非常感谢你花时间与我们谈论这些非常重要的事情。正如我所说，人们绝对应该
following you um on linkedin um because i think your advice is golden thank you very much i've enjoyed it i've loved going on good lovely well um it's been an absolute pleasure um and i'll look forward to yeah connecting with you more on linkedin in future awesome see you soon thank you wow what wonderful advice and i have to say that since recording this episode with ian i did try to move my um business banking account to starling but they've turned me down ian they've turned me down they said no um so yeah i will consider my options but i believe it is easier to get approved for starling personal bank so i might well try that it's never too early to start thinking about financial planning and it's you know there's no greater time than now so hope you found this really useful and thought-provoking i would love any thoughts you've got about this episode come
在LinkedIn上关注你，因为我认为你的建议是金子般的。非常感谢，我很享受。我很高兴能参加。很好，嗯，这绝对是一种荣幸。我期待着未来在LinkedIn上与你更多地联系。太棒了，回头见，谢谢。哇，多么美妙的建议。我必须说，自从和Ian录制这一集以来，我确实尝试将我的商业银行账户转移到Starling，但他们拒绝了我，Ian，他们拒绝了我。他们说不。所以，是的，我会考虑我的选择，但我相信申请Starling个人银行账户更容易，所以我可能会尝试一下。开始考虑财务规划永远不会太早，而且现在是最好的时机。希望你觉得这非常有用且发人深省。我很乐意听到你对这一集的任何想法，来
and join me on the aspiring psychologist community free facebook group any thoughts you've got about this episode. Come and join me on the Aspiring Psychologist Community free Facebook group. And if you've got any ideas for future episodes of the podcast, please do get in contact and let me know. If you'd like to leave me an audio testimonial for the podcast or the book or the membership, please check out www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast. Thank you so much for being part of my world. I will look forward to delivering the next episode of this podcast to you from 6am on Monday. Take care. Psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book.
加入我的“有抱负的心理学家社区”（Aspiring Psychologist Community）免费Facebook群组。如果你对这一集有任何想法，请加入我的“有抱负的心理学家社区”免费Facebook群组。如果你对播客的未来剧集有任何想法，请务必联系我并告诉我。如果你想为播客、书籍或会员资格留下音频推荐，请查看 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我期待着在周一早上6点为你带来下一集播客。保重。心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是“有抱负的心理学家”，一名心理健康实习医生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。
I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有完美的成为临床心理学家的道路。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。